Why are we outside? ...Alright, whatever.
*Sees zombie children* Oh....HMMMMMMM
Okay well, they're dead,  okay.... *Zombie pops up*
Ohhhhh.. I don't like this..
Not that bad, come on don't be such a baby about it. *contemplating life*
*Zombie pops head up from the hill* Hello, sneaky
Sneaky sneaky... *Pulls out gun*
*BAP*
*Zombie falls down in a hole, geting impaled*
OH... Oh oh....Oh... Oouuh.. Ew...
Whoop de doo, someone didn't wipe properly *brief giggle*
Oh....*Sees deformed zombie*
*Typical Markiplier maniac laughter*
*Giggles a tad* She looked at me cross eyed right there
Alright, anyway. *shoots zombie casually*
Seeya, okay.
What the hell- uh oh, I SEE A SKIMPER SKAMPER OUT THERE.
Oh,  you wanna play a game of peek-a-boo?
Well I  know where to play..
*WOOSHES INTO THE EARTH*
WHOOOH
HUYNNNOH
DYEGHUUUUH
WAAAAAAH
HaAaAaAaaA
* Awkward silence*
HWUAAAAAAAAAAH?!
*babipoo's sneaky giggling*
Boop Boop! *hollow knocking sound*
*killshot*
Boink
Boink x2
Boink x3
Boink x4
Boink x5
Boink x6
No? Okay
hayoooooooh.....boink (x7)!
*Weird giggle that sounds like a tank tread*
Oh, what a lovely mysterious white substance you have in your bowl...
Whoa... oh! Dark.
*Lights begin to shut off* Oh! Uh-Oh..
Hmm.
Well.
*WOOSHING NOISES*
I'm not a hundred percent sure, but I think the secret is riiiight here--.
Oh. Okay, well....
aAaAA, WOAOHH
WOAH WOA WOAW WOOWE
WHAT. THE. HELL. WAS. THAAaaat..?!
Do I have boobs?!?
Hellll yeah! Oh hell yeah!
I've got boobs. Hell yah! Oh look at me! Either that or I've got incredible pectoral muscles
But I think I got boobs. Hey, hows it goin' there? *singing*
Oh, hey, how's it going there? WHAT THE F—WHOA!
AaUGH!
*Ominous ringing accompanied by whispering and vague mumbles*